i had a conversation a moment a little
while ago about
a tiny henka wouldn't it be better when
on kinder negari for them to do that so
they can take the wrist
where here the wrist gets small and they
don't want to take it
and i said yes the problem with that is
let's have a look um
let's see what the problem is i'm on a
line
in keenan nagari
in kihon i would go like this i would
get off the line i would turn and be
here
kino nagari
you do this you get off the line you
turn there
but the point was but they haven't got a
lot of risk to grab
so if i go this way
they've got a better wrist to grab
but if they do that way what happens is
as a teacher you start getting more
confident and you start doing that now
did i get out of the way of my partner
no
and it's because by doing that it makes
him naturally
go around me
so now i'm getting lazy yeah but i'm
good so it don't matter you know it's
and this is a problem what happens with
teachers just because they can do it
they they forget the basic principles
basically it's boys
i must do tana henko the same whether
it's kinder nagari
i must get out of the way and say please
go past i don't want to fight you
so that's why
if you work on linking them together
linking them together
i
the techniques all start looking the
same
it's
the philosophy starts all becoming the
same
i get out of his way on all of these
i mean i don't want to hit i don't want
to hit this big guy do i
you know i had to get out of the way
even to do it
i had to i had to get out of the way
even to perform it
but you will see some teachers who have
done karate and aikido they'll go hey
you know they're not moving an inch
because they know they can go bang bang
bang
why didn't he fall down
because i wasn't in his energy moving
i wasn't in his energy i had to keep
moving till he fell down
the the seminal go on until four o'clock
and those who want to go home thank you
and those who want to stay will be
working on
throwing without touching and we'll be
working on energy work but out of 100
people 99
aren't interested
so that's why i don't really teach it
all right but just lately i've had more
and more people sort of pestering me to
do it
you can see
what i'm doing
he doesn't know why he's falling down
but we'll go into that but i don't want
to make it sound as if it's exotic or
special but those who are interested in
will say the energy
work
it's a stepping stone to start it
am i doing it
i am nick i become nick
please go past
i'm a hundred percent
given to him what i'm not doing you can
use the yin and yang you can use the
dark side of this energy and go
down
i will get
it oh yeah
i pulled him down because i wanted it to
work
so there is a black side but if you're a
good person you'll overcome that and
your ego will realize it's not the way
to go through life and you're
and you'll do it
with love rather than hate or want
all right why does he keep falling down
i don't know what's wrong with him but
he should see a doctor
right so i tried it out on a 12 year old
russian boy
he's like
he was the best 12 year old i've ever
seen he i made him do a first q test
it was superb i said do you want to go
another woman sort of study for it
30 minutes later he comes back he says i
said see i'm ready
he speak english ready i thought 30
minutes you must be joking
but it's on the it's on the youtube
you can see his test i can't believe it
30 minutes and he'd worked out all i
want what i wanted
i done this on him and i said to him
please have a word with your mother when
you come home because you've got a
little bit of cotton here
and and i said that bit of cotton
i said you shouldn't have it hanging
so after doing this a few times
he's going right
he's trying to see the cotton that i'm
pulling
so i it proved to me that uh because you
can't con children well i don't think
you can so it proved to me that i must
be i've worked something out correctly
you're not going to get there in a hurry
you're not going to get there while
you're trying to lift your arms you're
not going to get in there while you're
trying to do all this
it's only when the time is right
but if you want a stepping stone to
understanding of senses aikido
you need to do yoga because how sense he
done it
you need to meditate
you need to realize that it's not me me
me
it's him him him
and you should be hit to help everybody
i mean i know that uh if you was
need somebody that was out in the road
and you saw them fall off their bike or
something mostly would go out there i
doubt if anybody wouldn't go out there
and say are you okay
all right so it's inbuilt in us
naturally but when we're doing aikido we
seem to have this
thought of
i've got to get the right whatever
the cost
you know
all right so i can't think where i was
but um
could you try and go over for all of
what we've done this morning and then
the other person try if you can't
remember it just do what you can
you've got five minutes to perfect the
art